all right let's flip it to chiefs
raiders one of the best games of the
week one of the best games of the season
yeah
you suspected initially that the chiefs
had learned a lot from what the raiders
did back in week
five right what did your review of the
film
reveal in that regard i i it revealed
that that
the the chiefs came out with a different
game plan
that completely different game plan you
know something we have seen them work on
a little bit the last few weeks we've
seen this infused into their game plans
you know whether it was carolina
and certain plays but you know the the
buffalo game
in the bad weather right they've had and
found
a new part of their offense to go wait
when teams play us like the raiders did
in week five the first time around
we need to run the ball just a little
bit and we have to have more of a short
passing game
to bring people up a little bit and then
open up the deep stuff or either way we
just you know
pick away at them for six and seven and
eight yards and that's what the chiefs
did
i've never seen andy reed call that many
short passing plays
be that patient all together in the
offense and i would say
mike i'll make a bold statement and say
i don't think i've ever seen kansas city
execute play for play for play for play
for play
the way they did in that game it might
be the best execution
pipe for play i've ever seen them have
because usually they're one of those
teams
right mike that's you know oh it's two
series don't work so well
and then also there's three series that
are awesome and then it's two or three
series where you go up they're you know
bored in the sleep again
and then it's two or three touchdowns
again and it's a little all over the
place
they were phenomenal and surgical which
we don't usually see them do
and that was different and i think also
scary for the rest of the nfl that they
have that
yeah it's kind of like usually they're
that cobra that just waits and waits and
waits for the big strike
it was more of that systematic if you're
going to work so hard to take away
anything down the field we will be
patient we will take what's available
yeah we will harness the greatness of
patrick mahomes and
and use it for plays that
a lot of quarterbacks could make right a
lot of guys can do what patrick mahomes
did
but if you're going to take away the
ability of him to do spectacular things
down the field
fine we'll we'll do whatever we have to
do to win i mean that's right
that's kind of the attitude the chiefs
have had we thought we'd see more of it
with the running game but
hey in that west coast style offense a
short passing game is basically the
running game and that's what it's always
been and that's what it was and
and uh it was the perfect counter to
what the raid was
figured out it's just a hell of a chess
match and and i really do hope
that they meet again in the divisional
round i want
steelers chiefs in the afc championship
because i wanted to be resolved on the
field who the best team is in the afc
if not the nfl but along the way i'd
love to see chiefs raiders a third time
i i i mean i would too but i would be
scared that they would ruin that party
we want to see in the afc championship
game you know they're they're scary
i you know hey we talk about it now this
is what's the scary thing about the
chiefs too
every team's got their kryptonite the
raiders are building a team
to beat the kansas city chiefs they are
and i mean the discouraging thing for
the raiders is
you played almost a perfect game and you
lost you know that that
that's i think you know frustrating
and the amazing thing about the chiefs
is yeah the other team played perfect
against you and they're built
you know in a lot of ways perfectly to
beat you and
you still couldn't beat them you know
that's what's amazing about the chiefs
you know there they were playing a team
that you know kind of looks like they're
kryptonite but yet they find a way to
win the football game they're
unbelievable that way and how he can
make plays they can adjust their players
make plays at the right moments
uh whatever that is but yeah they have a
real threat within their division
uh and uh you know between that
offensive line the raiders have derek
carr
and gruden have the spagnolo defense
down and how they want to attack it
and you know we've seen that their
defense gives kansas city issues that
would be a scary matchup i'd get scared
that they'd ruin that party and all of a
sudden we see raider steelers in the afc
championship game
and that mindset for the raiders and
this is the way you have to deal with
the chiefs you know they're going to
score their points you just have to
score more and in two games this year
it's 71 raiders 67
chiefs they have found a way they have
outscored kansas city we we saw the
broncos
trying to build along those lines the
chargers as well
you're only going to slow down the
chiefs for so long
you have to outscore them and and maybe
they will now weather could be a factor
if and when they get together because it
will most likely
be at arrowhead stadium but uh i i hope
we see
round three but i agree with you you
know for as fascinated as we get
by those playoff upsets and what a great
story that gives us for the short period
of time it robs us
off right the better game the next week
yes
that's what i get scared of when we get
to that time of the year in the playoffs
and everything like that
i i more of the times than not root for
the you know the better teams
because i just want to see the better
match up the next week and i want to see
the best possible super bowl
and all those type of things but either
way the raiders
are real you know they're a player in
the afc i'm not saying they're going to
the super bowl
this year but i think hey the right
matchups and they get in the playoffs
they could be scary certainly with the
way derek carr is playing they're
secondary
and uh i got to give john gruden a lot
of credit for what he's doing out there
and let me just say this i would not
refuse to watch
steelers raiders yeah that'd be cool all
the marbles no doubt
prudent and tomlin right right yes yeah
70s style those two who got that old
school style about them anyways
that would be pretty damn good you're
right the last play for the chiefs the
one that delivered the victory we talked
about it yesterday how travis kelsey
popped open when patrick mahomes used
the threat of the run to
draw jonathan abram toward the line of
scrimmage
what do you what do you say if you're
paul gunther
or john gruden to your defense on how to
better handle a situation like that in
the future yeah i think the the big
thing is
right you know field goal doesn't beat
us
touchdown does so let's protect against
the touchdown that would be probably the
first thing i would say
the second thing that i think got a
little lost in translation here too
is and now and i understand abrams is in
a tough spot he sees a quarterback like
mahomes who can run
the red sea has parted and he's got 10
yards at least in front of him
so he's there and if you're watching
here on tv you see 24 at the 10 yard
line
he should be back where travis kelsey
kind of catches the football
okay but he sees mahomes step up in the
pocket and go there
but to me this is the big the big
coaching point mike here
the chief's got no timeouts let him run
the football
go ahead let him run the football let
him take the 20 seconds off the clock
there
and they're gonna be in trouble of
whether they want to score that
touchdown or not
after that i mean it's going to be down
to okay maybe you got to play or two
more and then you might have to kick a
field goal
so that would probably be the other
thing that they said to abrams yesterday
watching the film back
and look this is something that reminds
me of the approach that the titans took
last year when dean pease was defensive
coordinator why bother
blitzing patrick mahomes you're not
going to get him anyway
why bother even taking the bait when you
see him start moving toward the line of
scrimmage because the moment you react
he is going to burn you
into the spot that you vacated and if he
wants a run
let him get him especially like you said
no timeouts come on
come on let's go and we're going to
treat you like a running back i mean
again i don't want to tread lightly here
but
but you got to pick your poncho in a
little bit that's been the mantra let
him run you want to run
come on run bring it and uh uh
that that's i think that it's always
smarter to avoid getting beat by his
arm than by his legs especially like you
said with no timeouts
there's a lot of things you got to be
aware of jonathan abram's a young player
but uh that that that is the smart way
to do it because once you
he's you're playing into his hands yeah
that's what he wants
when you approach him yep he's gonna
zing it right back that's exactly right
he's he's
he's as as good as we've seen
manipulating coverage
in extending plays uh ever in the sport
already i mean i don't really care he's
up there with the all-time greats in
that department whether that's rogers
farv
you know elway back in the late 80s
whatever but once he gets out of that
pocket yeah he's running and his legs
and arms are moving
but his eyes and his brain are thinking
where can i throw a 30 yard laser too
that's what he wants to do
and yeah i would be one to air run let
him run for 8 or 10 yards
don't let him throw lasers for 60 yard
touchdowns
so how much will the buccaneers yeah who
have
five days now to get ready for this
onslaught will they just
lift the the game plan that we saw
defensively are teams going to start
doing that and forcing the chiefs to do
the sustained drives
you know do it and we'll try to match
you score for score
but we're going to force you to stay on
the field we're not going to we're not
going to give up a quick strike now
you're going to wear your defense though
potentially
if you do that all game long but will we
will we see the buccaneers do you think
try to do the same things that the
raiders have done i i
i do yes now you know the good thing
paul gunther everything hey he's been
he's coaches great game plans they've
run some cool coverages that
you know some defensive coordinators
might not exactly know how to run or the
nuances of those coverages
and also the other thing too where you
know we talk about the raiders being the
kryptonite a little
the raiders have a really damn good
secondary
i mean hey mike mayok he he proved a lot
of people wrong with his damon arnett
the kid he drafted at ohio state that
people weren't you know
thinking was a first round talent and
i'm one of those guys hey he
he deserves he's they they killed it
there so that they've done a good job
trayvon mullen abrams you know they got
guys at least that can really cover
let alone they coach up some cool zone
coverages too i would think todd bowles
has some of that element certainly but
two you know there's always an advantage
for that team in the division
because hey the raiders got to play them
twice last year
they probably took a few weeks during
the year to study the kansas city chiefs
in the offseason then
they get to play them again twice this
year so they probably have a much better
feel for how kansas city likes to attack
and breaking them down
to a different area to where other teams
might not be able to hit it but
i would think generally mike that would
be the approach if you have a pretty
good front four
let them go play coverages and try to
make mahomes and company be patient that
way
and and take your chances that way other
than being over aggressive and i don't
think you have much of a chance at all
you made me think of something when you
said that because they have a
quarterback
who comes from a team that has
experience
dealing with the chiefs and dealing with
them fairly effectively
i don't know how much of that knowledge
tom brady carries in because he's
focused on his
job during the weeks that the patriots
are coming up with game plans for
dealing with
the kansas city offense but surely he
picked up something
that could be of value to the defense if
if the bucks want to try to draw that
out of him right i i
you know brady's yeah he's smart enough
knows what what his defense was doing up
there in new england and like
little things or nuances that were part
of the attack for
for patrick of the homes and i mean
yes they've done it new england did a
great job of always kind of containing
mahomes for the most part to where yeah
he might be able to add a few ideas if
they ask him
or go that way you know but it just that
again it depends on
the relationship how those coaches are
i've been on some teams
where coaches are cool like that and
they want to find every
ounce of information out and hey what
did you know you know anything about
what you guys did against them last year
like what
what was you know what did your coach
say blah blah blah you know just that
but then there's other coaches who don't
ever want to let their guard down they
have all the answers already and they
know everything
and they'll never ask anybody the other
device so i don't know what department
todd bowles falls into there bruce
arians tom brady the whole relationship
i i don't know
of course the best coaches are the ones
who will take in every potential shred
of information that could be useful
make good decisions about what works
what doesn't incorporate that into the
game plan
think of it maybe in the third quarter
if you hey how about this he said
something you know
those are the best coaches who are in
the moment who are willing
to depart from their way and welcome any
and all input because it can only make
you better it's not going to make you
worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports